what do you expect the next couple of
years will look like
not the short term but let's call it the
midterm what is the next three four or
five years the midterm look like
actually i'm very bullish i love this
time
actually to be honest so i you know i
chose the fj
during the downturn because the you know
as john doe would say the mercenaries
leave and the missionaries stay
so um anybody who so this is the best
time to be a founder it's the best time
to be a seed stage investor
um because one if you're a founder you
have less competition
you're probably doing something you
really care about your employees are
grateful they're
not trying to keep them you know they're
all they're grateful for whatever for
for working for you
and all the big companies are cutting
their r d budgets and so when the
markets come back you know and you can
pick your number the spanish flu is i
think like 18 months
it's something between six months and 33
months but in the next one to three
years within that time frame
the markets will come back all the big
companies are going to suddenly be
focusing on growth not
profitability and they're going to have
a vacuum of innovation and you're going
to get acquired for a huge multiple we
started out of the yammer so adam
persona who was the cto of yammer he was
one of the founding mentors and
alchemists and so
the companies were housed out of the
yammer offices in san francisco and
yammer was funded you know after the
lehman crisis in in january of 2009 i
think
they launched and then they got yeah
yeah and then they got acquired in 2012
for like 1.2 billion
and that what and the reason why was
because nobody had built out an
enterprise
social network in that time and then
when the markets tipped
microsoft was like oh we need an
enterprise social network strategy and
they
paid up for so i love this is the best
time to start a company if you can get
the cash
and it's the best time i think to be a
vc because
founders are grateful for the money and
you can invest on
fairly good terms um it's the the issue
is getting the cash to survive the
downturn but
what are you advising people in your
portfolio who are coming to you saying i
have the six months of runway
i can't raise money what do i do you cut
you cut your burn now as painful as it
is if you have any burn to cut
because again this is a it's a it's a
non-linear return on the your runway for
every week
that you um you you you make that
decision earlier so if you cut you know
half of your burn
right now you're gonna save six months
or three months of time fifty percent if
you cut that
when you're three months in you're gonna
have like six weeks or four weeks so
cut it now you'll be surprised at how
your startup will survive even if you
don't have roles that you think are
critical
it's amazing how startups it's so true
people think like i can't i had one
founders like i just
maybe i should shut it all down instead
of going from whatever x number to 50
of that or a third of that and i was
like yeah you may want to
try having a third of the number of
employees to see how it feels
and you know what they felt more
efficient oh yeah
you're especially if you have dead
weight the employees are actually
grateful to get rid of the dead weight
and then usually
that you go through this like little
trough where people you know it's a bit
traumatic but that
shock yeah but then yeah there's a bit
of shock but then people actually
re get back to their core i would say
where this also happens is that if
this is advice for the founders that are
listening is that if you do have
investors
your investors may say hey you know just
keep going and you know we'll we'll
bridge you you know
and that's a very dangerous scenario
that nobody's going to necessarily coach
you on because your incentives are
misaligned so explain it
if you so if you have a board and you
have six months of cash
and you bring this issue up to the board
your board of vcs
may say don't worry about that just
execute and we'll try to fundraise three
months from now and if you can't raise
we have your back we have your back we
have we're managing
you know 500 million dollars we can
write you a check now
if you do that when you're within um 12
weeks of
of cash and the company's about to die
your
the board members have a lot of leverage
over you even though they may not
have this intention the reality is is
that your fate it's too late for you to
fundraise
and so if you go to the board at that
time they may provide terms that are not
necessarily terms that you would
normally want to take so
when you're six months out you want to
have that honest conversation with the
board and say hey i want you guys to
bridge me
if you don't i'm going to cut my burn
yeah why don't they bridge you right now
so that you can sleep at night why make
it
the company doesn't want to bridge you
because they don't want to take the risk
so they want to have somebody else they
want to see if somebody else is going to
come to the fore
and they can wait and in fact if they
wait they'll also have more leverage on
the terms so
and this is a little bit this is being a
little bit overly cynical i don't want
it you know to
uh it's a real it's a real phenomenon
that does occur whether it's intentional
or not
in some cases it's not intentional in
some cases it is intentional yeah and
and this is something that i don't think
founders get taught
until unless you have a third space not
not your board not your investors
but something else and and so in that
moment you need to tell your vcs look
if you're not stepping forward it's okay
but then i will cut the burn
for the company yeah and we will make
cuts because i need to make sure that i
have at least nine months of visibility
yeah and that's where you think it's
nine months is
the minimum yeah and so you can just
keep cutting to keep it at that
uh well you cut i mean if you're in b2b
you can there's obviously a bunch of
operational things you should you should
accelerate your receivables delay your
payables
do everything you can to preserve cash
furlow your employees ask
employees to make trade-offs on cash
versus equity so there's a lot of
different things but
you need to ideally weather out the
storm which i think i
you know i personally you know the rule
of thumb is nine months
i feel very uncomfortable with nine
months i've always been 18 months i'm an
18 year old
yeah i think 18 months i i want three
years but like
i think i think i think you should try
to see if you can get to the great thing
about 18 months is
you can put your head down and work for
nine to 12 months
and just really focus on those customers
and the product and you know
um at the end of the day
what is the most important thing for
founders to remember
when they're running an early stage
company
well i think the most important thing is
to validate the need before you build
the product
so your time is your most precious
resource and
put faith in your worth in your team and
your customers
not your investors or techcrunch like
you it's a it's a it's a noble job to be
a founder
and you should source why you're doing
this because of the customer that you're
serving
or the team that you want to work with